normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
from The Economist one in five Young
Americans think the Holocaust is a myth
our new poll makes alarming reading so
they released this poll and you can see
18 to 29 year olds 20% believe the
Holocaust is myth 30 to 44 it's just a
little bit less than 10 45 to 46
floating around 1 65 plus almost zero
the Holocaust has been exaggerated same
stats basically slightly more 18 to 29
year olds just over 21 maybe around 22
or 23% and then about the same numbers
for the other demographics I find this
fascinating um in light of what we just
saw with the universities so this all
this all makes sense I love by the way
that Alise stonic absolutely just
eviscerated so this is this is a tweet
from her she says I was proud to Cod
lead the 2020 bipartisan never again
Education Act to provide K through2
Federal grant funding for Holocaust
Education and and have been co-leading
the bipartisan reauthorization this year
but these numbers from the economists
are absolutely appalling chilling and
unacceptable I'm not here to tell you
what your opinions should be on any of
this stuff but I will but my point is
this the universities ban pronouns right
if they they ban ra misgendering they
say fat phobia creates an unsafe
environment if you state facts that are
offensive to the individuals they will
come after you this is what we saw uh um
the Free Press as bar Weiss's
organization put up this video and then
they defended and said if you call for
the genocide of Jews well now we got to
talk about the Constitution right you
can see where their views align and you
can understand then why you're also
you're seeing these two things play a
role why are young people so likely to
believe the Holocaust is either a myth
or exaggerated because these professors
right why are these professors willing
to defend under the guise of
constitutionalism the the right of
students to organize protests calling
for the the genocide of Jewish people uh
because they hold these View themselves
they will ban speech that offends their
power and then run and cry and hide
behind the Constitution to defend the
speech they like the bigger picture here
is universities social media are
subverting the young people in this
country to make them
oppose the worldview of the United
States our own our own histories and
thus I mean this what you got to
understand about this this data right
here it doesn't change yeah but 18 to 29
year olds in 10 years will just be in
the 30 to 44 year bracket right and so
your 65y Olds drop off and the bracket
continues down so what we need is making
sure we win this culture War yes to
shift things back in the direction of
pro-america believing history things
like that well and again I I've been
arguing that one of our greatest threats
as well is that culture social and
religious Warfare that we're seeing here
at home and that really starts with the
indoctrination that's going on in our
schools I mean it's also as I was
speaking yesterday uh at one of the the
Gatherings I I explained the fact that
you know it's intentional that we've
been removing Civics from our schools
because we don't want the younger
generation to actually understand what
their civic Duties are how to hold
government accountable and so all of
this in my opinion is just this
indoctrinated theory of how they're
actually doing things to try and weaken
the American values and and essentially
American exceptionalism of what we
actually stand for as a nation who's
doing it I mean the these professors
these uh universities these large donors
the George Soros of the world I mean
this is all part of it I mean your huge
endowments and who those actual alumni
who are donating into that are actually
I mean they would rather focus in on the
things like ESG CRT and Dei and
meanwhile strip out one thing which is
God that's what and so that's what we
have to start thinking about well said I
I think that some of these 18 to 29 year
olds might be trolling I don't know how
many of them were actually pulled but it
sounds like something an 18 to 20 ny-
old might do is troll the inter internet
and be like yeah I think it was fake but
like okay it is important to see World
War II from the German perspective for
sure it is I was taught purely American
perspective growing up it's nice to see
both sides but I think it's I don't I
cannot dispute that these people were
massacred that the the Jews are rounded
up on trains and sent to like
concentration camps and starved to death
do you think it speaks to Jen's cynicism
that they just don't really believe in
anything anymore including history and
any way it was presented to him and the
way Nick pentes like just has fun with
it he's like yeah whatever he just says
it cuz he get a L of people it's like
it's it's it's it's not just that it's
sorry Nick when when you have uh the
women's March the organizer of the
women's March you tablet magazine
released a story where they're
espousing insane conspiracy theories
about Jewish people the there's there's
a meme a joke about to figure out which
political faction you are simply insert
whichever group you hate into the
following sentences and then it's like
blank are responsible for all the world
wars blank control of the corporations
blank dox and it's just like you can
choose the 1% white privilege Jewish
people the Chinese the Russians and then
you figure out octarians yeah it's
basically just who do you hate the most
and you found you know so what's
happening is you have in universities
these professors we've seen this MH that
that woman from upen doing the kubric
stair you know what that is it's where
you tilt your head down and look up and
smirk while she's being asked is it
against the rules to call for the
genocide of Jews she look she look she
does the KUB spare smiles and goes in
certain contexts
it's like this is a person these are
universities that that have said you
better not use the wrong pronoun or else
well but it's interesting that you as
you pointed out earlier and correctly so
you're talking about how it's you know
we don't want our students to feel you
know shamed we don't want our students
to feel at risk but what about all of
the Jewish students right now who are
actually saying I don't feel safe on my
campus anymore I don't feel safe on my
universities I have threats against me
and we now have people who are actually
not just being you know investigated but
actually been uh arrested for making
threats towards other Jewish students I
mean what about their protection what
about their voice what about their
rights and and and and I'll I I'll
stress I always give my my my free
speech position is students should be
allowed to protest as long as they're
not harassing someone so they're hiding
behind the constitution in a way that
Free Speech Advocates would agree with
my point is that the only working in in
One Direction and and that's the issue
that I have with universities they want
to say that it's okay for you to do one
thing but then if someone say something
that's against your political view or
you believe then it's not okay which
exposes the hypocrisy correct that's so
the point I want to say right now just
to you know get across with uh uh
leftism is overlapping with Nazism to
the greatest degree of any political
ideology that exists not fascism Nazism
explicitly um fascism you can make an
argument about like what were they
actually speaking to as a political
ideology Nazism was like yes plus they
wanted to kill Jewish people so when you
add this into it and you've got
professors that are effectively it was
the late David Graber he hated this but
they called him the anarchist
Anthropologist he said that elements of
the left have adopted the
fascistic moral framework of there is no
truth but Power it's like I agree with
you there David and when you add into
the fact that they hate Jews and don't
believe in the Holocaust and want to
defend the right to call for their
genocide I think now it's Nazism one of
things that set the Nazis aside as a
fascist organization was their
ethnocentrism they were obsessed with
white supremacy so like seeing people
talk poorly about a race in any way sets
my alarm Bells off and so which which
political faction in this country wants
racial segregation again that's what I'm
concerned with if any of them want any
form of it it becomes very very
dangerous let's go back in time
California was trying to uh amend their
constitution to allow for segregation
based on race in public Contracting and
education I this was back in like 2018
they lost I was talking to a friend of
mine who's a liberal Lefty prominent
Hollywood person and uh you know they
had posted a comment in support of it I
had posted a comment saying like this is
shockingly offensive to someone who
comes from a mixed race background that
you would allow them to hold this
against me so she calls me and she's
like what do you mean that's not no
we're we're trying what they wanted was
affirmative action we want universities
to be able to help people who are
underprivileged and I was like how many
what's what's the population uh uh
demographics of California
and it's like oh it's like 70 something
per white and I was like so your
argument is that white people are
privileged are racist inherently racist
use these the systems of power for their
benefit and now you're arguing arguing
that white people should be allowed the
majority should be allowed to
discriminate against anyone based on
race in and public Contracting education
and that fixes the problem it's such a
hypocrisy I mean the way they they
handle themselves it's it's publicly
hypocrisy but when you understand what
they want to do you understand it's not
hypocritical at all it's exactly what
they want they want racial segregation
they want ethnocentrism or aarian is
probably a better way to put it I think
ethnocentrism is probably a fine way to
put it too they want race-based law and
when you add in the fact they hate Jews
and Nazis the Nazis specifically were
like Aryans first you know they were
obsessed with propelling one spe One
race species I almost said race is such
a silly term anyway it's not even a
scientific term but but then like the N
the Jews and the gypsies were like got
the brunt of the ha but it was everybody
if they weren't Aran like they were
second class or less and so it's either
you're going to say this race is the
best or we have to neap that race either
one is is leads to that totalitarian
Nazism crap and so I'm I'm All About
equality of opportunity man I understand
some people's ancestors didn't have a
lot of nutrition maybe because they were
born from slave camps like 1860s all
these slaves L out of the South happen
to have be from one area of the world
with a certain type of genetics and so
their an their kids don't have good educ
ation CU they didn't have good education
they didn't have good uh nutrition CU
they didn't so maybe their brains aren't
aren't getting what the nutrition they
need to really have Brilliance that's
real that we got to address that too but
it it's like in a free Society where
where it's kind of up to you to make the
best of it and like you got to trust
hopefully you have good parents it's
it's you can't like legislate the
solution you can't throw money at yeah I
do I mean I think that there needs to be
change at home on the family level right
all of these things we could say this is
an issue this is a problem but
ultimately unless you have strong
families nothing else matters and we see
this replicated throughout American
society right we are less engaged with
Community organizations we attend church
less regularly we are Stripped Away of
all the things that used to give us
strong tenants of culture and again
drive people back to their families and
that that is ultimately something that
needs more than a legislative change it
needs a psychological change in the
homes of every American well and again
you know thinking of someone who you
know for example if you look at my
background you know my mom and dad both
had drug and substance abuse issues and
we in and out of prison pretty much my
entire life my dad did almost 30 years
in prison my mom did almost 7 and a half
years in prison and I kind of bounced
house to house until I was finally
adopted and taken in by my grandparents
who kind of and again just a regular
blue color family you know my
grandfather's a welder my grandmother
was a stay-at-home mom who would do hair
on the weekends you know she had taken
her class through cosmetology school so
she'd do hair on the weekends after
church and things like this but you know
your socioeconomic status doesn't Define
who you are I mean that's the whole
point of the uh greatness of America if
you will and I think that's one of the
things they're trying to water down and
dilute and I think a lot of people also
have this issue of self- victimization
where they just basically say well I
can't do this because of my upbringing
well you know I wasn't born into money I
mean we we were thriving right above the
poverty line I mean I can remember when
my grandfather had a quadruple bypass
you know and he couldn't work any longer
and he was disqualified even though he'd
had five heart attacks from receiving
any type of disability benefits I mean
we live for for an entire year on around
$6,800 you know I mean there was a lot
of rice tomato gravy cornbread and you
know which now I absolutely crave when I
go back home you know but the whole
point is is that you know there's this
self-victimization that also is going on
in our country that we have to break and
understand that you know we are a nation
that believes in equal opportunity not
equal outcome and that's the difference
in my opinion between equity and
equality and the difference between what
the left and the right is trying to
bring to the table thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net